CBS News has confirmed the classified
intelligence president Trump shared with
Russia came from Israel the Israeli
ambassador to the u.s. said in a
statement
Israel has full confidence in our
intelligence sharing relationship with
the United States
critics say the Oval Office disclosure
by the president may have hurt American
intelligence gathering but the White
House says these leaks are a coordinated
effort to hurt president Trump major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning whatever the damage
done to US intelligence gathering or to
this new president's reputation as
someone who can be trusted to properly
handle classified information the White
House is still defending the president
even if that defense is contradicted at
times by the President himself mr.
president did you share classified
intelligence with the Russians after
ignoring questions president Trump
placed all questionable actions with
Russian officials in the context of
fighting terrorism we had a very very
successful meeting with the Foreign
Minister of Russia our fight is against
Isis
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
again defending the president made the
case that he was out of the loop on key
details the president wasn't even aware
of where this information came from he
wasn't briefed on the source a method of
the information either McMaster did not
deny the disclosures and claimed they
were wholly appropriate and talks about
terror threats to commercial airlines
national security has been put at risk
by those violating confidentiality and
those releasing information to the press
the White House alleges former Obama
officials are engaged in a coordinated
timed and deliberate attempt to damage
the president in a fundraising email to
supporters the Trump pence campaign said
there are people within our own
unelected bureaucracy that want to
sabotage president Trump Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
laid the blame at the White House I
think we could do with a little less
drama from the White House his stream is
watching the Democrats urged the White
House to release a transcript of the
president's meeting with Russian
diplomats what are the Republicans
afraid of are they afraid of the truth
why are they protecting president Trump
the president's sense of frustration may
be at the highest
point of his presidency to backlash over
the Comey firing and his latest
controversy about Intelligence Sharing
has led the president to scrutinize
sometimes harshly everyone in his inner
circle that includes son-in-law and top
advisor Jared Kushner sources tell us
Kushner was one of the prominent voices
endorsing the Comey firing and the
president is angry that that has created
such a political and legal firestorm
Charlie thanks major